these movies are all about family I
don't have friends
I got family did you know that Vin
Diesel's Behavior has been so
unprofessional at points that The Rock
publicly called him out he's even been
rumored to have made a director quit
this is the biggest drama from the set
of The Fast and Furious movies you
better not leave the rock waiting the
problems between these two allegedly
started when Vin refused to come out of
his trailer to film a scene with his
co-star Vin had already become known for
showing up late and shortly afterwards
Dwayne took to Instagram to announce
there's no other franchise that gets my
blood boiling more than this one he made
it clear that his female co-stars are
always amazing but that his milpo stars
are a different story some conduct
themselves as stand-up men and true
professionals While others don't this
offended Tyrese Gibson who wished that
Dwayne would be more clear and call out
names but Vin's name being missing from
The Rock's personal shout out to his
co-stars after filming wrapped for fate
of the Furious spoke
volumes still the two were apparently
able to mend Bridges we had a good chat
long ago and everything is the way it
should be but that doesn't mean the
drama with Tyrese was over then wasn't
the only one The Rock had beef with as
it turned out there may have been more
to Tyrese's input than we'd realized at
the time when F9 was delayed repeatedly
Tyrese took to Instagram to blame it on
Dwayne for branching off into spin-offs
pointing out that he'd been able to do
something similar but turned it down out
of respect for Paul Walker's memory Vin
Diesel rushed to his co-star's defense
insisting on Instagram that it was
unfair to say it is anyone's fault but
this did little to Defuse The Situation
considering shortly afterward Tyrese
threatened to leave the franchise if
Dwayne were to return for F9 this is
about as far as things got and it seems
that all became friends again after
settling the matter in private yeah
we've reconnected in a real way man
we're glad to see them all kiss and make
up though in the case of Vin Diesel he
may want to avoid kissing Charlize
Theron this on-screen smooch wasn't all
it was cracked up to be in fact Charlize
Theron said that kissing Vin Diesel was
a lot like locking lips with a dead fish
something that he obviously took great
offense to what yeah
what ouch way to go for the ego but as
it turns out Charlize wasn't trying to
embarrass him when she said that
apparently the kiss was scripted to be
bad because Vin's character was supposed
to have feelings for Michelle
Rodriguez's Letty not her character
Charlize probably wouldn't have said
anything at all if Finn hadn't gone
about bragging about the kiss he's
literally going around saying that I had
the best time of my life but hey if
you'd like something to brag about then
definitely consider giving that
subscribe button a click and in the
meantime let's talk a little more about
Michelle's character The Fast and
Furious franchise would be missing
something without Michelle and yet after
the release of f8 Michelle took to
Instagram to announce I hope they decide
to show some love to the women of the
franchise on the next one or I just
might have to say goodbye to a loved
franchise Michelle didn't call anyone
out by name but rumors suggested that
she was especially offended by Dwayne
Johnson and Jason Statham each receiving
their own spin-offs shortly afterwards
Vin posted a video with Michelle on
Insta where she praised him for being
the biggest supporter of strong women
even clarifying if I ever post anything
some suggested that VIN may be leaving
with Michelle if push found a shove
which actually wouldn't be the first
time he left the franchise but as it
turned out they didn't have to the
writers took Michelle's notes and used
it to transform Letty from a trophy
girlfriend to this really layered
character do you remember the first time
Vin left the Fast and Furious franchise
it was back before we knew how far
reaching the series would be to be fair
but still the first movie was such a
huge hit that you would think he would
want to return for its immediate sequel
especially when you considered that he
was offered 20 million to come back yet
Vin just wasn't that big of a fan of the
script and so we decided that he would
rather do The Chronicles of Riddick
instead are you gonna stop the monsters
now I am the monster you can probably
already tell that this was a bad
decision even Vin said that he shouldn't
have walked away from it just because
the script suck because there's an
obligation to the audience to fight no
matter what to make that film as good as
possible though in the case of Justin
Lin there may just be a Breaking Point
Justin Lin is almost as synonymous with
the franchise as Vin is he's directed
five of the movies starting with Tokyo
Drift and although everyone expected him
to continue along with the series for
years to come we were all stunned to
receive the news part way through
filming for the 10th film that Justin
would be leaving the family what a sad
day for the entire crew Universal
Studios blamed his sudden departure on
Creative differences but rumors suggest
that there may have been one major
breaking point for Justin and it's a
story we've all heard before apparently
Justin got into a major disagreement
with vin that ended with Justin deciding
that this movie just wasn't worth the
cost to his mental health binge just
kept on showing up late to set
unprepared and Justin had had enough of
course it's only natural for any family
to have at squabbles but even if they
wind up leaving the franchise for a bit
we can only hope that they can find
their way home again the way that Vin
Diesel did which of these onset
differences were you most surprised to
hear about and what do you think about
Justin Lin leaving the franchise make
sure to let us know down in the comment
section
foreign